on prend le pouls tout de suite sur le
terrain côté ukrainien junien chez ida
bonjour vous étiez ce matin encore à
marioupol comme la plupart des
journalistes vous avez été contraint de
reculer face à l'avancée rejoue vous
trouvez maintenant à zaporijia
c'est une nouvelle nuit qui qui se
profile sûrement plus difficile plus
écologiquement au vu de ce qui s'est
passé hier qu'est ce qu'il en est au
moment où l'on se parle quels sont vos
informations à vous et qu'est ce qui se
passe sur le terrain surtout
oui effectivement elizabeth on ne fait
absolument pas comment les prochaines
heures pour évoluer ni comment cette
nuit se déroulera c'est toute la
stratégie militaire de la russie on se
trouve actuellement à leur port i jah
qui se trouve au sud de l'ukraine et non
loin de la crimée alors contrairement à
plusieurs grandes villes qui ont été
bombardés aujourd'hui zaporizhya qui
contient environ 700 mille habitants a
été épargné c'est une ville qui se
trouve à trois heures de route de
marioupol à l'ouest de marioupol et qui
donc est l'une des destinations pour
ceux qui ont fui cette grande ville
portuaire où nous nous trouvions encore
ce matin il était 5h30 lorsque nous
avons été réveillés par de puissantes
déflagrations suivi de plusieurs
bombardements sporadiques dont une un
très fort qui a visé on le sait
maintenant une base militaire
ukrainienne ainsi qu'une position de
défense aérienne bombardements je
précise qu'ils n'ont pas fait de victime
d'autres bombardements ont été entendus
tout au long de la matinée par les
habitants en banlieue s de marioupol
mario paul abrite un port industriel et
marche sont très importants l'un des
plus grands d'ukraine et surtout l'un
des plus importants de la mer d'azov ce
port a été la cible de bombardements
et on nous a fait savoir selon une
source militaire du port que des navires
militaires russes étaient postés depuis
le milieu de journée en face du port le
long toutes postées posté sur la mer
d'azov pour l'instant ils n'ont pas eu
l'ordre de tirer sur la ville les
ukrainiens nous ont dit que s'il devait
y avoir un tir il y aurait réplique de
la part des ukrainiens dans le reste du
pays de l'est du pays il ya la ville de
cramatte hors stocks qui se trouve tout
près du donbass et qui abrite surtout le
quartier général de l'armée craignent n
qui a été la cible de plusieurs
bombardements tout comme à louhansk ou
encore comme l'a dit elena plus au nord
dans la grande ville de kharkiv ou là ou
là bas de multiples déflagrations ont
provoqué les interviews s'interrompt
julien vous retrouverez un peu plus